hey didn't you almost join the stones at
one point wasn't there some sort of talk
about that i was driving in from um
from mount kisco
right and um where you lived uh when i
was living and um
i was listening to the news on new and
it said the stones have now released
um five guitar players on the short list
uh
to join the band and um to replace mick
taylor and i just paid that toll the
first one from and i had while i was in
the toll i'm paying and i hear my name
and i
ah
what did he say and so i just i had to
pull over right listen to this
would you have joined the stones had
they asked
i think so yeah hell yeah i would but i
would say well i have to be able to do
my own solo records as well and then
keith said [ __ ] that yeah right of
course absolutely i don't understand why
mick taylor left that band that's crazy
what a great guitar player he was the
perfect fit for them i love ronnie
ronnie wood is perfect but but i mean
the songs that mick taylor played on he
was perfect yeah
but i guess he just couldn't deal with
it lovely melodic style he had some
bands you don't quit right i mean some
bands you stick with well yeah i would
think so yeah it might have been hard
for you to be in the stones because you
got your own thing going i'd probably be
dead do you think so you mean partying
maybe who knows you know i mean you
would have been out of control but what
do you mean because the stones are so
out of control you would have become out
of control you think
well i don't know
and
i i think that um
maybe not maybe i'd still be there yeah
but they never auditioned you or
anything it wasn't like that no i never
got i i think ronnie uh ronnie was um
a pretty obvious uh choice and and and
keith one of keith's best friends